I'm tempted to say President Bush to ask
him what was he thinking back in 2003
but I won't do that I think in many ways
I wouldn't be content with interviewing
just one person I'd say that I'd love to
have the time and the resources to pick
up a farmer in a drought infested part
of India hoods on the verge of
committing suicide as 4,000 farmers have
done this last year because they felt
their life was so hopeless that ending
it was the only way out I'd love to
interview a Russian oligarch to find out
how he feels about his billions and and
what difference he can make to his world
with that I'd like to interview an
African potentate stashing his millions
in Swiss banks and ask him what he feels
about the condition of his people I'd
love to interview a Hollywood star and
and see what contribution she thinks her
performances in her lifestyle are making
to the victim to are making to change
the planet into the into the better
place that we all want to leave behind
when we leave it and so on and so forth
I could give you 10 more examples but
that's the sort of set of interviews I'd
like to do I think there is no one
person on this planet who has all the
answers that I'd like to find
the question that I feel we should all
be asking ourselves is in what way is
this planet different for us having been
on it and hopefully different for the
better but if not just different